[Laughter]
why did why did you press it you're just
not physically
attracted in this episode we have a
special guest who's going to be voicing
me I'm button fan critic afficionado
Cody Co here to voice it for the first
time they're pulling the first people
I'm n she's like I'm nervous I'm nervous
right now how are you I'm so good isn't
that the wilderbeast who yelled last
time a the gogoy the gargoyle sure well
Willer Beast gargoyle same whatever
title you want to give it the G yeah but
now she looks more tame maybe they put
two in her
neck got that tranquilizer dark yeah
yeah the way she was screaming it was
wild bomo
CLI
bomas
CL this is Satan welcome to
hell I'm playing this is the button
welcome please flirt now Emil Emil yeah
jayen jayen pleasure okay go ahead what
how old are you 26 how old are you how
old do I look you look 25 ooh you about
to say what I you say 25 or 35 oh
what
you like the gym he he went out with a
bang he said like he said uh wilderbeast
do you like the
gym how are you Miss Bon nice to meet
you did they say Bon's back yeah they
got Mr Donkey Kong in the building yeah
bonco yes wow I see you work out yeah
yeah how how
wow buddy what do you do what do you
doing she's like you work out I can see
and his response is what do you do cuz
you don't work out that's two times that
Jim has come up but anyways what do you
do I'm personal trainer oh your personal
train I love to work out do you work out
I do but you could help me work out a
little bit more that face bro that face
is so
awkward he said do you work out she want
I do
you see my parents wouldn't have ever
made that face they would have been like
no you don't they would just they be
like no this is what you need to do this
is where you need to get to uh you're
ugly and you're fat what do you think
about B D yeah bald his bald hair he got
no hair boy how come your
bald did she go boy she said boy
boy she said boy does that bouncing that
[__] it comes with five fingers pointing
at you
boy in my culture everybody's like that
in Bulgaria
Bulgaria what did you say say it again
Bulgaria abs the dam clip I will it's
unacceptable a lot of muscles though woo
you look like you can Crush something
yeah and why did you uh reject him
muscular and he looked at me like he
said oh she chunky
monkey Hey listen all of how how dare
you say that you heard what she said
about herself bro home girl called
herself a chunky
monkey could you see them matching Maybe
hell no he's just waiting to hit that
button so damn I'm slow this time damn
EJ nice to meet you all nice to meet you
nice to meet you I'm EJ by the way oh
I'm Shen nice to meet what are you guys'
types uh taller than me EJ how tall are
you I'm 5'8 okay how tall is that I'm
5'6 so okay a little bit taller than
yeah a little bit yeah these two do not
look like a match whatsoever no she
looks like she just came out of 70s
Diner and my homie looks like he just
got done adding Hydraulics to a Cadillac
hi hi nice to meet you nice to meet you
to your hair thank you how long you guys
been single for uh 2 years okay yeah how
about you may since May that's like four
months yeah pretty much four months what
happened uh I was getting cheated on oh
yeah how long were you all together 10
months yeah go red I kind of set myself
up there oh oh my
God that's foul bro he said go red right
after the dude shared something
to is it cuz he got kitted
on how are you doing
fantastic uh my name is Austin
Austin
[Laughter]
[Music]
Buton y Austin you get me every time
this guy's on camera but
M Anya how often do you change your
hairstyle uh every day every day what
does that mean mean the
wig mean a wig are you into that I mean
is that coloring it are you just doing
different I have a bunch of wigs blows
oh okay yeah diversitile yeah [__]
Austin says that it's a red flag did you
really say that but this is a w that's
different like it's a little different
if you're color your hair like every
month but this is a wig what does that
say about people if they're coloring
their hair every month it usually means
we're going through some [__] through my
experience they're coloring their hair
very often it's not
really oh you were too
slow I don't know where to put
myself
look at Cody's face you know what you
should do right now if I'm in the
bed
Austin why did why did you press it
you're just
not physically
attracted
I mean hey she did say the other guy
wasn't physically attracted or not her
type in so many other words so you can't
really get mad at her
but oh unfort oh you got me you got me
all oh it's okay she mad she mad but I
understand though I understand I mean
Hey listen a bunch of people so far said
I don't find the other person physically
what's happening
well she just took it bad I understand
what and I from what he said there's a
difference between you're not my type
when I say you're not my type it's about
me when I say you're not physically
attractive it's you okay I see what
you're saying if you say hey you're not
my type you're really protecting the
other person's feelings when you're
saying you're not attractive y' don't
give a
[__] don't give a [__] what are you
looking for uh not that God damn he
didn't even say not her he said not that
like she's not even human you're pretty
brutally honest huh that wasn't that
bad how you doing I'm great this a
little early isn't it it's a little
[__] early I'm like I cannot look
hung over yeah I got Drake tonight so
are you going to
Drake so am I I might they're both Drake
fans so I already know I don't like
either of them oh you don't like
Drake I appreciate Dr I appreciate Dr T
hold on how do you feel about all the
debate about him being the greatest
rapper ever I don't think that's true
can you argue with his album sales is
there anyone who's sold better than him
who's been on more tours who's been more
watched heard worldwide yeah but he
doesn't do just rap so all his album
cells are not just rap it's not just
testifying his rap it's testifying his
R&B it's testifying his pop to be in
this age you have to understand hip hop
is not with the old head all the old
[__] who just be like want to wear
bandana go Thug Life That's sh over bro
what do they want to do Thug Life yeah
all that stuff yeah is there some sparks
flying right now I'm just honestly I'm
just vibing with you I think you're just
fun that's it yeah yeah yeah you're fun
too you got seats too or are you like in
the pit I have backstage
passes so you're suck so you're sucking
oh my God
w
wow I don't know what fresh and fit
podcast you've been watching but chill
out man said back s p you got to be
second but I ain't mad at it cuz he's
just he's
just he's just chilling he's just saying
wild stuff yeah if you can take that po
p take that take that take that they can
Vibe they can Vibe if she thinks it as a
joke it's an indication of dick can
actually still Vibe gotcha that's why I
probably won't get invited next concert
cuz I won't suck dick
sorry oh my I just got
gaslighted wait why why did you reject
her she's fine going
back I don't know what that
mouth it's like he felt one up by her
for having backstage passes so he had I
don't think that's what it is at all he
just wasn't attracted to her no you
notice the way he said are you vibing I
don't know I'm just feeling her energy
that to me sounds like he didn't find
her physically attractive but let's find
out if I'm right
Aus okay I'm sorryy you missed out okay
okay yes
slay yes slay whatever I I I hate the
words slay yes it's just funny to see
things from like drag culture and just
make it out to like the most mayonnaise
filled tables just to be like oh you you
you found 20 dolls on this floor slay
like yeah you know so I told him to
leave and he left right after him he
like oh thug life it's
like oh my God you guys are insufferable
yeah it's like so corny aggressively
corny like like a invasive aggressively
corny that's like an invasive species of
corny aggressive like they're
encroaching on Words that were fine and
neutral and cool and then making it so
corny like this is revolted aggressively
corny can I do ASMR on you H sure
actually that might feel
nice oh you like
that can you moan again canot me no no
no
no are you're an animal person uh I like
cats I want a cat specifically cats are
better than dogs I like it yeah I like
it I had I had one crawl on me and it
made me feel uh I was scared and then it
made it go away when I
was
it's making me think of that guy from
The Jubilee video uh they have to be
funny or at least like unfunny enough to
like think I'm funny cuz I you know if
if I can Whittle them down and like oh
God he's so funny it's actually I've
just tricked you into thinking I'm funny
that I think that would be good yeah the
guy the vegan guy oh yeah um do you guys
um are you guys wearing underwear yeah
me too it's just it's comfortable I I
would try to wear that every day you
know guys who try to just pretend
they're weird mhm and that's their whole
personality like I'm awkward yeah yeah
yeah yeah what craw were you like
cracked the [__] out cuz that's cracked
out you're giving me like crackhead
energy which is not bad one of my cats
what I do about it how do I fix it
you're giving me crackhead energy what
why am I cracked out what do I do to fix
it I'm frightened it's not CRA why are
you frightened uh are you not are you
not frightened I'm like disassociated
feel like there's something I don't know
what it is it's definitely aniet no I
mean I feel like I'm having more fun
with you than I've had with anyone else
for sure what are you feeling right now
um I think you're beautiful a thanks
yeah and um I like the way that you talk
how do I talk elabor I can't do nothing
about that bro don't look at me like
that there's nothing I can do about that
it's just that now right now what you're
feeling is that it's both of them it's
really both of them it's her and him
he's like watching a John pretend he has
a lot more money than he has and then
watching a hooker pretend to be more
more interested than she actually is so
she puts on a fake voice I sense
something's happening here maybe tell me
what's happening I I need Aderall
man I I have some in my backpack
unprescribed I just like prescrib but we
got the national short is going on right
now for ad are you guys doing a drug
deal right
now I would give it to her for free I'm
prescribed so it's not even like oh yeah
me too why are we talking about that
what what what do you what do you like
create Crea what is your uh I like you
you have the same name as my brother and
that's [__] with my head he's a Wan
man named Jesse which is the exact same
thing as my brother is even though we're
vibing I could
never you know what I mean but like if
you had a different name I would not
have like I swear on my life I'll give
you another chance if you guys want
Jesse maybe you just want to like change
your name or something I'm not sure
because like I enjoy talking to you cuz
I think you're like a [__] psycho in
a good way but like you still have the
same name as my brother wait let's and
my brother's like one of my least
favorite people to ever exist in this
world like literally well let's maybe we
can work through that guys I'm going to
light up red one more time and you can
make the decision see if you can she
past his name okay well it's up it's
it's her call here how do you spell your
Jessie is it my it's different than your
brother it's it's spelled with a a z and
an
X all right congrats
wellow that was uh
interesting I think I uh I think I need
a day off anything else
granted